what's your thoughts on the manusphere
i have mixed feelings about it but
largely positive
like um
i've been a sort of uh
observer of it for like 15 years or so
ever since the early days of like pickup
artists in the early 2000s and
um
uh david deangelo aka
evan pagan is a good friend of mine and
i've like appeared at david angelo
events
like 15 years ago
it was
strange to see like
second and third hand
ideas from like my early work
getting kind of recycled
into manosphere
like wisdom or or good advice or often
bad advice
uh and then get into arguments with
manosphere guys who are like miller you
don't understand human sexual dynamics
at all this is my [ __ ] word like
preach let me preach let me explain to
you how sexual selection works like dude
you're literally quoting back to me
something i wrote in 1994
like thanks but
i think for a lot of young men um
they need
like
older successful role models who can
explain this stuff to them in a very no
[ __ ] unpretentious way
you know and that's what tucker max and
i were trying to do with our mate book
it was kind of like conjoined
evolutionary psychology with
like brutally simple
language that even your average like 20
year olds could understand
and
you know sometimes the manosphere
guys get a little bit
um
overconfident i don't know what's up
maybe their testosterone supplementation
is too high or whatever but
they get a little feisty and a little
combative but
um
i just think if you're if you're a young
man listening to this it's
it's important to choose your role
models
uh carefully
and like try to choose guys who are
actually
succeeding at something other than just
giving advice
like who can actually have good
conversations with a variety of people
on their podcast or actually are making
money in crypto or have actually founded
some company that's doing well or
um
who aren't just like anonymous behind
the scenes kind of
manisphere trolls
the thing that surprised me when i was
watching uh reading mate your book which
is [ __ ] dope by the way if there are
guys out there that want to kind of
learn the principles of evolutionary
psychology for mating and i think that
women should read that book as well
because
where are all the good men at is
probably a pretty fair question to ask
at the moment and if you want to be able
to coach whoever it is that you're with
in order to be better or to be able to
understand what it is that you actually
want
really really [ __ ] good book it'll be
linked in the show notes below um but
one of the things that really surprised
me about that book was how long you guys
spent in a dating book for men
explaining to men about what it feels
like to be a woman in the dating space
that was
that was a like a really really welcome
surprise one of the problems that i have
the specific problem that i have with
the manosphere is it treats women like
the enemy fundamentally that is the
primary problem that i have with it and
i really really try to toe the line i'm
happy with uncomfortable insights right
i'm [ __ ] all day i'll talk about them
because they're cool like watching the
fallibility of your own world crumble in
front of your eyes is this something
kind of humbling about that like we're
looking up at the night sky right like
it's all and it's dread at the same time
it's kind of cool
but
you can push that so easily you know the
hypergamous nature of women that they
really don't have that much control over
and saying oh you are actually only a
five out of ten so you shouldn't be
thinking you need to get with a man that
does that's homeless and lives on a
couch and smokes weed all day like
all right man like is that not being
[ __ ] done to death where you get
idiot thoughts from miami and put them
on a podcast and do whatever but yeah
there's a big section where you try and
explain to men about what it's like to
be a woman um understanding girls
feelings around physical safety
objectification creeps being
self-conscious and stuff like that and
that is so [ __ ] important i think for
men to understand
yeah tucker and i did you know
a podcast called mating grounds we did
like 250 episodes or something
and that
that insight about hey guys you know if
you want to have success with women
maybe
radical idea
maybe you should spend like at least a
nanosecond
to look at the world through a woman's
point of view
and the number of guys we had call in to
that podcast going like wow i never
actually did that
like even though i have a mom and
multiple sisters and many like
ex-girlfriends i never actually thought
okay what would the dating scene be like
if i felt physically vulnerable
sexually vulnerable
if a lot of the guys who approach me are
straight up like sociopaths
and bad dudes because they're the only
ones who have the courage to be super
assertive
right so you get a biased sample of men
or online you're gonna buy a sample of
like a lot more trolls than good guys
because trolls are very very active
and just like spend a minute thinking
about that and then think
how
how is i'm you know an honorable man who
has his [ __ ] together
can you like
break through all of that noise and and
chatter and fear
and kind of like present yourself as
hey how you doing my name is blah blah
um
just like have a normal conversation
so
perspective taking is
i think really crucial
in this
what do you think there's a about the
zero-sum mentality that i said about the
manosphere because that's how it feels
to me it feels to me
like
a lot of the
fundamentally um good
but delivered poorly
and with a snide topspin advice from men
sees any man's gain as a woman's loss
like it's it's weird that a lot of the
time they're talking about um how to get
women and to get with women and then
when a woman does there's this sort of
low-key
admission that that's somehow their loss
like because you gave yourself away to
this guy that we've coached to try and
get himself into the position of how he
can have sex with you now you're a [ __ ]
yeah
yeah that's totally toxic
it's bizarre and the
the irony is a lot of the guys in the
manosphere if you ask like do you
believe in capitalism or like
communism and redistribution they're
like capitalism why oh because like
economic exchange is positive some
because we can all get wealthier if we
like provide good good goods and
services to each other
and then you're like okay that makes
sense in economic markets why do you
think the mating market is somehow
zero-sum
like this there's some obvious
low-hanging fruits like if you have
dating apps that are really really good
at matching people based on
genuine compatibility
that's a win-win for everybody it's way
better
than living in some medieval village
where you have three potential mates and
none of them share your interests
and probably can't even read
right
so there's there's so many positive some
uh
ways we could we could restructure the
mating market to work better for
everybody what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace
you